[Music]
tonight new information about a deadly
shooting that happened
thanksgiving morning thank you for
joining us at 6 30 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez it actually
happened in a number of locations all
across henderson
including a 7-eleven that's on lake mead
parkway and center street
joe moeller has new details that he
uncovered inside the police report
the people involved allegedly shot at
nearly a dozen people that morning that
7-eleven store behind us he was turned
into a crime scene on thanksgiving day a
total
of four people were shot here one of
them did die now here's a look
at a memorial that's growing outside of
the 7-eleven 22-year-old
kevin mendiola jr was killed outside of
the store
now here is video of the scene thursday
in the police report we learned there
were three people who were allegedly
shot
at random people around the area they
were identified by police as sean and
christopher mcdonald and kaylee lewis
police say they were in a black car and
pulled up next to several drivers and
opened fire that morning after shooting
at several drivers the three eventually
came to the store where they shot four
people
mendiola was killed the others were
taken to the hospital after the shooting
here police say they drove down lake
mead parkway and shot someone else in a
car
that person went to the hospital as well
later that day the trio was allegedly
involved in an officer-involved shooting
in arizona
and that is where they were taken into
custody police were able to match
descriptions from witnesses to security
cameras
here's another look at this memorial
outside of 7-eleven police
say they believe christopher mcdonald is
responsible for mendiola's death
they say he's now facing a murder charge
with a deadly weapon
reporting in henderson joe mohler 8 news
now